what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to how Clarence Thomas got red
pilled by Thomas so before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today it has the utmost softest
material and all the women will come up
to you left right and Center speaking of
digestive issues this is caused by a
potential toxin that is in all of our
quote unquote healthy foods that
scientists have been telling us to eat
with a fraudulent food pyramid for the
longest time and this potential toxin
causes digestive issues according to Dr
gundry a world-renowned cardiologists
this is affecting millions of people
Nationwide warning signs include weight
gain and fatigue and digestive
discomfort stiff joints and even skin
problems well Dr gundry explains that
these side effects are often mistaken
for normal signs of aging because
digestive issues develop usually over a
matter of years and sometimes even
decades I can assure you that the damage
is probably caused by these healthy
foods and it's far from normal the good
news is you can easily help fix the
problem from your own home guys it is
very simple you just have to know which
foods are actually healthy and which
contain this hidden potential toxin so
you can go find this yourself at gut
cleans protocol.com Pearl that's gut
cpr.com Pearl click the link in the
description below the video Let's Play
the video so a friend of mine who knew
about this he was a quadriplegic from
polio and a very close buddy of mine he
calls me up in my office and said
Clarence I'm reading this review in the
Wall Street Journal there's another
black guy like you his name is Tom
s and it's a review of his book race and
economics I'll let you I bring it over
tomorrow and I said no I'll come get it
so I ran down and just like got this uh
book review by Michael Novak and there
it was there was Tom soul and I got his
book eventually read it after some
trouble read it like a a thirsty person
off the desert drinking water and there
it was was reconciled finally somebody
was telling the truth and the I went to
St Louis and this is 76 and 78 I go to S
I'm working at Monsanto someone says
they know how passionate I am about this
Thomas sa Guy and um they mentioned that
he's going to be at Washington
University law school where he was in a
on a panel with Professor Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and uh so I go over and it's
interesting to see just how influential
Thomas soell was like Candace Owens
talks about how he influenced her now we
have a Supreme Court Justice talking
about how he influenced him Thomas Sol
is really a legend of our time follow
the poor man around he was trying to
leave and I was a stalker
and I I admit it and he signed my book
he autographed my book and looked at me
kind of awkwardly and I would see a him
again after I moved to Washington when a
bunch of black staffers were giving him
a hard time and I defended him and he
would come over to my office I shared
with three others and we would talk uh
and he took my number and I took his
calling him you may as well just forget
the number if he gives it to you just
burn it you'll never get him uh I
learned that the hard way and well I can
now but back then he wouldn't there's no
way I know I've been trying to get this
man for an interview for years
completely unsuccessful I have not been
able to do it and he called me he took
that number that I had given him and he
called me to come to the Fairmont
conference and that's how started it and
that started a friendship that has
lasted from 19 uh the late 70s to to the
present or maybe the 1980 to the present
and I want you guys to pay attention to
the time period because a lot of times
people think that like 50 years ago was
so different with the woke stuff but
I've actually heard that there's less
feminists today than there was 50 years
ago because there's more alternative
media now and back then it was like the
norm so all this like woke ideology it's
definitely gone further but I I don't
think in the last 50 years we've really
had a generation of people that
consistently didn't buy into this stuff
on some level and one failure for us
after all that exuberance at the
conference is we have had nothing to
show for it other than one little report
we had no
organization um Clarence Pendleton tried
to do it and they isolated him and beat
him up and he went to Civil Rights
Commission
eventually then um who am I thinking of
Lee Walker had a small branch of it in
Chicago um and he kept it going he was a
great guy but the the negativity was
over helming so one of the things we
hoped that would come out of this is we
don't have that s similar failure where
it ends when we close the conference
door uh there's got to be more than that
or you'll be here 40 years from now
telling people that 40 years ago you had
a conference and nothing came of it and
you're thinking that is two
generations that is two generation that
is four score you know I really love
seeing how much like Thomas so has
impacted really like an entire
generation there's so many people out
there that have been impacted by Thomas
soul and the thing about Thomas soul is
he knows how vicious and Ruthless People
can be when you are telling the truth
the problem is when you go against the
truth it goes against like an entire
agenda there is an entire agenda
dedicated to lying to women and if you
ever go against the narrative that maybe
it's not okay to pay single mothers to
be single mothers that all of these
policies break down the family you will
be attacked and that really is why
Thomas soell is so hard to get into an
interview he's like an academic that
really I just don't think he wanted to
do media but he wants to tell the truth
so you know guys make sure you go
subscribe to his I don't think he has an
actual Channel but you can listen to
like his audiobooks online like the
video on your way out and get yourself a
woman sh vot t-shirt I'll talk to you
guys next time